كوريا الشماليه صاروخها جاءت كوريا
الجنوبيه لتجريه ايضا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه منورات جويه مشتركه وتعتبر هذه
المناورات الجويه جزءا من مناورات بداها
البلدان الماضي وتستمر لمده عشره ايام
وصفت بانها غير مسبوقه وانها اكبر من
نوعها منذ خمس سنوات تجري هذه المناورات
شمال العاصمه الكوريه الجنوبيه سول وعلى
بعد 30 كيلومترا من المنطقه المنزوعه
السلاح التي تفصل الكوريتين
في غضون ذلك ذكرت وكاله انباء ينهب
الكوريه الجنوبيه ان القوات الجويه
الامريكيه ستعيد نشر قاذفه القنابل بواحد
في شبه جزيره الكوريه تحذيرا لكوريا
الشماليه والطائره بواحد به قاذفه
استراتيجيه فوق صوتيه وتعتبر عماده سلاح
القاذفه القاذفات الامريكيه وقد دخلت
الخدمه منذ ستينات واخضعت لعمليات تطوير
وتحديث متواصله